hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game uh from round four of the
uh vhs.com grand swiss it's a game
between maxine bashar lagrave and anton
demchinko it's a great attacking game
and it will surely improve your sunday
at least a little bit so let's dive
straight into it and check out what this
game is all about as it will affect uh
well probably not only the standings but
also maybe even uh the candidates
tournament uh for the next cycle so
maxine with the white pieces opens with
e4 with e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 going for the roy lopez and
now
not the usual a6 the morpheus defense
but rather g6
this is sometimes called the mr barnes
defense sometimes dismissal of defense
sometimes the fiance defense uh all in
all black is preparing to fianchetto the
dark square bishop which is very very
interesting in the rue lopez so here we
have c3 maxim goes for that um central
occupation right away bishop to g7 and
now d4 striking in the center e capture
c captures and a6 now challenges the
light square bishop bishop to a4 and b5
so bishop back all the way to c2 now the
e4 pawn will be nicely defended and d6
now and here
you have to decide how do you want to
develop
for example h3 is possible if you want
to prevent a move like bishop to g4 uh
d5 is also playable fabiano caruana
played the d5 here against shakira
mamidyarov in the granchester rapid in
uh leuven in 2018 and he lost that game
uh but here yeah we have h3 which means
that black is probably developing this
bishop to b7 uh as well uh all of these
squares are taken d5 can be played this
will be taken so it doesn't really make
sense to develop the bishop the
uh the d7 uh but okay uh here we have
knight to f6 black is now also ready to
castle white castles and now uh castles
is a move that has been played in uh all
the instances that this position has
been reached but here we have bishop to
b7 by demchenko and it is now only as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how mvl continues we
have a3 uh and now comes castles we have
rook to e1 and now rook to e8 uh we have
bishop to g5 you could instead of rook
t8 maybe play h6 prevent bishop to g5
but if bishop to g5 doesn't bother you
then h6 would just be a weakening
move
as
this is the the defensive structure that
you prefer
upon the light square is your dark
square bishop fan cathode in between and
you do not want to push those pawns
unless you have to so rook they at first
he's not worried about bishop to g5 this
is what maxine plays and now h6 now you
chase away the bishop bishop to h4 and
now knights to e7 now uh not worrying
about this um pin here but also just
going after the e4 pawn so knight to c3
defending the pawn and now knight to h5
uh it's very interesting you could go
for g5 here and it's probably a move you
should play and then after bishop to g3
now knights to h5 attacking the bishop
and once the bishop moves now knights to
g6 with excellent control over the f4
square
is what you probably want to play here
but he went for knight to h5 right away
and here he allows maxim to uh really
really grab some initiative and uh maxim
plays e5 here i will just show for fun
because i know how much you guys enjoy
this queen the d2 is a super fun move uh
very nice developing move you're ready
to bring your rook into the game and now
g5 no longer works because now this
sacrifice will be deadly bishop captures
h captures queen captures and now your
knight is hanging after knight to f6 we
can play e5 and this is just bad if
captures captures then located d1 will
be really a problem for black and if
knight after d5 even e6 can be played
and this is just terrible for for black
uh so just thought you guys might wanna
know know uh this as you know it could
happen in your own games when black is
ready uh to push g5 or rather when black
is not ready to push g5 so instead maxim
goes for e5 we have queen to d7 uh and
now comes d5
another interesting approach is just e6
just weakened at the g6 spawn and for
example after f captures we eliminated
the defender of the pawn and after rook
captures uh even knights the h for now
going after this pawn it looks very ugly
to play this for black but okay maxime
has a different idea he plays pawn to d5
and now asking uh what is happening with
with this pawn and it's very interesting
if you go after this pawn then knight
captures and if bishop captures uh well
then just rook captures and you have to
take care of the the the
knight somehow if knight to f4 we just
go after it with rook to e4 and then if
knight goes back uh the h5 we just
played g4 so we're gonna get rid of this
knight from here either way and if you
don't do that if you play something like
this then we happily you know capture
this and it's uh
well it's it's a dead lost position for
black there's not gonna be all that much
you can do about this
uh so instead after the five we have
knight to f4 right away and only now e6
and this is uh where the
uh well this is uh approaching the
critical moment of the game f captures
on e6 was played we have d characters on
e6 attacking the queen and now the
question is can black capture this pawn
on e6 and the answer is not only should
black capture
uh yeah i messed that up yes the answer
is yes of course black should capture
but this was not played in the game uh
if knight captures an e6 is played it
looks very dangerous but black can
indeed hold this for example knight e5
going after the g6 pawn
attacking the queen of course the punk
the knight cannot be captured the queen
is hanging we're gonna play bishop
captures an e5 which already looks bad
because you've given up a very strong
defender but after rook captures an e5
we play c5
uh idea being that it's just a very nice
move and also bishop to b3 going uh
after this diagonal can be met with the
simple c4 so this is very important and
now if you go for something like bishop
captures rook captures and knights to d5
now attacking the rook also threatening
knight f6 check to pick up the queen uh
we're going to capture this and after
queen captures we're going to play rook
8 to e8 so
nicely defend everything and now you
can't really play rook that you want to
continue piling up because just rook
pawn captures rook the queen is now
nicely defended so you're going to have
to play rook to d1 and here we basically
trade down into an equal end game just
captures captures captures we're going
to play captures here and after rook to
d8 we can play captures captures and now
bishop play goes captures uh and we have
an equal end game bishop against tonight
for five points each uh so this is what
can uh be reached after a move like
knight captures an e6 although you know
many other lines can be reached as well
however
queen to c6 was played here which looks
excellent uh as it puts um incredible
pressure on this uh g2 pawn so if the
knight moves you could get checkmated
but it also loses the game for black so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute best move for
maxime here
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh on finding this
incredible idea as it's not easy to find
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course rook to
e4 that's the good stuff not only do you
put something in between that queen and
bishop so you you have more
uh space you know to maneuver uh as you
don't get checkmated but also you're
threatening to pick up the knight here
and there's no good way to
uh take uh take care of this if you play
something like g5 uh which seems like um
you know it should work you we just
captured that rook captures on f4 and
now if this is captured then queen to d3
and now you're really getting destroyed
there's no defense here for black so
what was played in the game is knight e
to d5 uh just uh
adding another defender to the knight
and also trying to trade off one of
white's pieces so maxime captured on d5
we have knight captures on d5 and now
rook to g4 going after the g6 pawn so
how do you defend this well there's no
good way to do it rook captures an e6
was played and now you are okay maybe a
throw captures you can capture here but
now maxim doesn't even bother with that
he just plays bishop to b3 you know
another reason why this pawn pushed the
c5 was very important to play the c4
move at some point
but you know in order to eliminate this
pass pawn you had to you had to go into
this so here bishop captures on b2 black
will grab some pawns here for the
exchange uh rook to b1 bishop captures
on a3 and now of course knights to d4
attacking the rook and the queen queen
to e8 and now knight captures an e6 we
have queen captures on e6 and the queen
to d2 now so now you're not worried
about uh you know uh anything here uh
because you've made room for rook to d1
which will put more pressure to the
knight here but also you're just
threatening queen captures on h6
followed by rook captures on g6 and this
is game over so h5 was played attacking
the rook here and here uh maxime just
played rook to e1 and it was in this
position uh on move uh 28
that anton dimchenko resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
because you have to move the queen and
you have to keep an eye on the knight if
you play something like queen f7 rook to
f4 and there's no uh defending the
knight anymore you have to move then
bishop captures knight just wins other
than that you don't like you could play
queen to f5 then rook f4 again uh you
don't have to worry about this because
the knight is pinned again we're gonna
pick up this knight it's not a problem
and uh what you could play is something
like uh queen captures anyone with check
it seems like maybe it should be
possible we get two rooks for the queen
but still just queen e6 check and we
also pick up more material you know we
we really don't care here uh and
probably we can even just deliver
checkmate with our wither queen and the
the the bishops
but yeah after rook to e1 temchenko
resigned and a very nice victory for
maxime bashir lagrave which puts him to
three points uh and that is excellent
because uh there although there are
several people on uh three points so far
after four rounds it is only furuja who
is up uh three and a half points who is
currently the sole leader of the
tournament and in uh round fifth uh
around five in today's round it will be
uh uh
versus maxine vashila grab so they are
fighting for that spot in the candidates
for sure but also fighting for the
number one french player uh spot because
as you know alright no longer is
representing iran he is now representing
france uh he had a few years of
representing no one uh i believe two
years could be more uh but now he's
representing france and he's current uh
furuju is currently the number one uh
french player well i think he's not
currently as of tomorrow he will be
because then the rating changes but uh
if um he loses the mbl uh today could be
could be very different so we'll see
what happens uh you know with with
everything uh so yeah that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it a very nice
attacking game and it really shows you
how sometimes uh uh here like in this
position uh you really have to go for
these ugly positions and you know find
moves like c5 just to be able to meet
bishop to b3 with c4
to survive such crazy attacking games
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to holden i hope you uh win
many games uh and even more of them with
the evans gambit uh and i would like to
thank george northworth the uh frank
russell of brian stube and uh rajasthan
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of this spectacular tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day